good morning John I'm in a target and
I'm tired and I don't feel good but here
I am I'm going to have to figure out
something to do for the next 15 hours
and I really hope that it's at least a
little bit interesting I've been a
target for about five hours now and I am
really bored there's not a lot to do
here
hey nerdfighters came to see me why sure
oh now this is just why why why do you
put yogurt in the workout section nice
warm yogurt good job consumer aside from
being an excellent ninja master
balaclava is good for staying warm in
the cold Montana winter however it
didn't call it a balaclava they call it
a baklava I feel like a little bit of a
jerk for complaining about my punishment
when you really didn't do anything and
you have to get a root canal today
though as you pointed out you did break
the basic rules of dental hygiene this
is why every year for our entire lives
mom has bought us a toothbrush and and
what did you just ignore that there are
lots of people in this Target and they
they don't think I'm normal
Hank oh my gosh you guys I've been a
target for 12 freaking hours
Catherine just came to hang out with me
at the Target and we have been doing a
lot of math in this candy aisle to try
and figure out what candy is the worst
for you and we're doing that by figuring
out what has the most calories per gram
for a long time we thought that it was
going to be Reese's peanut butter cups
and then we thought it was going to be
the Dove peanut butter cups but it turns
out that it's the Lind or peanut butter
truffles with five point nine calories
per gram more expensive too you get what
you pay for which is chubby Oh
one last heaping spoonful it's a
horrible idea you suck
John you have to face your fear of
heights and go on the Frog hopper for a
full frog hop session and while you're
up there I want you to tell me you're on
me John see you on Friday